[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hailer jumped is a sequence Tom and I
have been talking about for a number of
years tome will be the first actor to do
a header jump on camera
halo jump this high altitude low open
military jumper 25,000 feet opening a
shoot below 2,000 feet and sneak into a
foreign country without being detected
that's the idea of Halo
there's a lot of risks in going to
25,000 feet the audience can tell when
something's being cheated sound it's
important to be doing it over real
there's dangers of hypoxia and the bends
you start losing your mind but you don't
realize it we had to develop a special
helmet that is both a prop and a
life-saving device the first phase of
the hello sequence was building a wind
machine that was large enough for us to
be able to rehearse so we built one of
the world's largest wind tunnels no one
thought it would require over a hundred
jumps to get the scene we needed the UAE
had they not stepped in we would not
have been able to accomplish the
sequence we've been doing five jumps a
day on the Twin Otter in the afternoon
we'll do three c-17 jumps and it's
challenging we're shooting a nighttime
sequence the light has to be perfect
we're gonna get one shot a day you have
to shoot it as close to sunset as we can
so we have exactly three minutes
every day to get the shot
I can't just get on the plane hood go
you have to spend twenty minutes on the
ground breathing pure oxygen so that you
don't get decompression sickness the
plane has to climb to 25 thousand feet
although the lighting turns from white
to red you're talking about Tom jumping
out of a plane was traveling at 165
miles an hour falling at 200 miles an
hour at least a position himself so that
he lands exactly 3 feet away from the
camera with 20,000 feet beneath him the
risk of a mid-air collision we were
really concerned about there's always a
ticking clock in filming a movie but
it's not usually the earth flying up
towards you oh I can't wait for an
audience to see this I still can't
believe we got it
[Music]
we gotta talk need to rethink this out
of my way Hunt Walker we got a problem
there's a storm when we need enough talk
of FEMA parents
altitude 25,000 feet
there cannot be peace without first a
great suffering the greater the
suffering the greater the peace the end
you always fear is coming it's coming
blood will be on your way I prayed to go
that it wasn't true
Solomon Lane escaped in Paris
and now the world is at risk this is the
CIA's mission you use a scalpel I prefer
a hammer
this is a bad idea is it ever good one
honestly he's not just some observer
he's an assassin
I trust anybody outside in this room
you go rogue he's been authorized to
hunt you down and kill you that's the
job
now our Phoenix
[Music]
what are you waiting for
I'm jumping out a window oh sorry
good luck wind up stops Ethan Hunt
who's everyone he ever cared about
you don't understand what you're
involved in you need to walk away
Ethan's not who we are
maybe we need to reconsider that
[Music]
accept it even if lost this one was done
this time
what's done is done what we say it's
done
Jim Todd oh my god
I know what you're thinking maybe
they're not here for you maybe they're
just here for me are you willing to take
that chance you have something I want
right now that makes me the only person
you can tries to get you out of here
alive I think I'd like to go home now
[Music]
it's definitely new mission it's a big
emotional entertainment story Ethan Hunt
in this movie finds himself in a much
more personal journey reader out in this
is the best mission yet it's a tougher
mission the end you always feel with
this one Tom's reason sort of doubled
down and has done a Spectre is 'king his
life literally for movies he doing by
the best not to hook
people talk about the action but what
they're responding to is their
investment of the characters need to
walk away it's to take you places you've
never been
it's to show you things that you've
never seen and it's to put you in that
experience right there with him what do
you think you're doing harder it may be
your mission but this is the CIA's blame
it doesn't take off without my say-so
we need reliable intelligence that we
did it now this scenario is precisely
why the IMF exists the IMF is Halloween
Allen a bunch of grown men in rubber
masks playing trick or treat and if he
had held on to the plutonium in Berlin
we wouldn't be having this conversation
and his team would be dead yes they
would
that's the job and that's why I want one
of my own men on the scene to appraise
the situation
agent Walker special Activities his
reputation precedes you use a scalpel I
prefer a hammer my man goes where no one
goes you had a terrible choice to make
recover the plutonium or save your team
who chose your team and now the world is
at risk
Simon myself invented
that is the core mission of possible
team the team is reunited but also new
elements have been reintroduced which
create a much bigger threats that
they've never faced before
I've trust anybody outside this room
this is the CIA's mission you use a
scalpel I prefer a hammer Henry Cavill
is something of a wild-card way the IMF
in the way hunt looks at him is like
he's the enemy because he's being forced
upon the team
he's not just some observer he's an
assassin
that's the job McHugh and Tom have put
together us symphony of actors
Rebeca focus on returning so i like the
fact that Ilsa is a match for Ethan
the journey that Ethan Hunt and his team
go through and there's huge stakes which
great Benji last what are you waiting
for
I'm jumping out a window oh sorry good
luck
your mission should you choose to accept
it I wonder did you choose not to the
end nor was feared is great
and the blood will be on your hands the
fallout of all your good intentions you
had a terrible choice to make in Berlin
one life over millions and now the world
is at risk this is the CIA's mission if
he had held on to the plutonium we
wouldn't be having this conversation
this team you'd be dead
yes they would that's the job you don't
understand what you're involved in you
need to walk away please don't make me
cuts for you how many times as hunts
governments betrayed him disavowed him
cast him aside how long before a man
like that has had enough
we are
[Music]
so how is he oh you know same always
there
how's he doing find it best not some
hooker
none of this has ever been attempted
before flying a helicopter takes a lot
of skill to put someone like Tom into a
situation like this is almost impossible
to imagine he came to me and he said
we're gonna go to Airbus and we're gonna
learn how to fly a helicopter and be at
2,000 our pilot in a very short period
of time take something like three months
of eight-hour days just to become a
novice helicopter pilot Tom needed to
work around the clock to reach the level
of skill the sequence needs there are
very few students that have his level of
dedication and focus thank you almost
aerial chases you'll see from a
helicopter
we don't usually turn the cameras in so
we've developed these rigs over the last
couple months where we can basically
hard mount two cameras to show that
Ethan Hunt is flying the helicopter
without anybody else every camera
position has been designed that you can
see that tom is doing everything himself
it's super important for a movie like
mission to be doing it all practically
and for real Tom doesn't want to it's in
the green screen the audience's can tell
when something's been cheated
for safety all the pilots get together
in the morning and they discuss very
clearly where they're gonna be and what
their positions are for every shaman
look down and I'll take it over the
waterfalls I enter it right away it's
great the most dangerous part of the
arrow sequence is really that there's
more than one helicopter in the air we
have 13 helicopters in the production
the ones on camera doing aerobatic just
a few feet from each other it's pretty
well throughout the entire sequence
visual contact and there's Todd he's a
pilot he's acting and who's the camera
operator before anyone you at all the
scary part was the 360 downward spiral
most planets wouldn't attempt this good
corkscrew turn is very challenging for a
pilot it takes a lot of skill a lot of
practice
you make a mistake somebody's gonna die
from it
I'm gonna go each spiral looks like he's
going to crash
ribbit-ribbit
that's what I want Howard that's my cue
very upsetting here Chris absolutely
[Music]